um what you need to know today starts in
green bay where the problem between the
packers and quarterback aaron rodgers
continues it's finally real now to the
extent anybody was like well we'll wait
and see what happens
if and when he shows up for mandatory
minicamp now
there's reason to say uh oh
doesn't mean he won't be there for
training camp but he's not there for
mandatory minicamp and let's start it
off chris cause we talked about it
yesterday extensively and i get
complaints from people that we spent
time talking about yourself what the
hell else were we going to talk about
yesterday it's the reigning mvp of the
national football league who has held
out of mandatory minicamp who's ever
done that what franchise quarterback
ever does that what reigning mvp is ever
anything but all in with his team the
next year it's the most significant
story in the nfl and i got pushback oh
oh baby spent 40 minutes talking about
aaron rodgers yes yes why wouldn't we
chris
i mean of course he's he's the biggest
story in the nfl right now yeah and and
like you know everything you laid out
why wouldn't me it's mandatory mini camp
it's relevant to the day
you know we know he's still not happy
and like you said the situation's it's
unheard of where it's the best player on
a team an mvp you know is dealing with
weight a team trying to replace him and
of course he wants security and all
those things so yeah i mean listen we
haven't seen anything
like this uh that i can remember really
other than maybe since john elway and
and maddox right in the early 90s maybe
similar to this but i feel like that was
even done in a different way um so of
course this is going to be the
the major
story on on the show
the one guy
who is blameless
in all of this the one guy
who has above all others the right to be
sorry in advance manchester pissed off
about what's going on is the guy who
didn't make this mess hasn't contributed
to this mess and is just taking care of
business with a 26 26-6 regular season
record in two years head coach matt
lafleur here he is yesterday talking
about the situation
i'm not going to get into my
conversations with aaron and the
communication and
i think you know
naturally optimistic but uh you know
again we'll take it day by day and just
do whatever we can to help remedy this
situation how much if anything do you
lose by not him not being here for these
three days and how much that answer
change if maybe he's not here for the
start of training camp either
well steve i think aaron's got a a ton
of experience and
he's not a guy that i i
worry about particularly that much he's
a pros pro
i know he knows how to take care of his
body and get himself ready to play so
that that is not
much of a concern from for us at all
two quick observations on the tail end
of that christopher first a prose pros
at mandatory minicamp if you're a pros
pro you're there for the things that are
labeled
mandatory you're there pros pro
mandatory camp goes together secondly
takes care of his body last time we saw
him he's down 15 pounds he's he's eating
okra or something like i don't know what
it was a tom brady method yeah he's
definitely on something
right right yeah he's he's not looking
like quarterback body right now he's
looking like post football body right
now so i don't know that he's properly
taking care of his body so i i i
look leflore
is saying what he has to say to not
further inflame the situation but he has
to be beside himself and like i said
he's the only one in all this who has
the right to say this is not my mess i
didn't cause this
i haven't contributed to this mess and
i'm the one that has to go out and talk
about it yeah no i mean listen he's
gonna have to deal with it that's why
he's the head coach there's no doubt
about that i mean first off rogers yeah
it is a weird situation but i do think
he's he's a guy that again we're not
going to worry about him coming to
training camp out of shape or he hasn't
thrown enough footballs and he's got
tendinitis in his elbow that that's what
he means by that and i also think
because of this you know
again i know we talked about this with
the cleanse and all that a few weeks ago
when he was on with kenny mayne that's
one of the reasons i didn't think he'd
be at you know uh the mandatory mini
camps and otas remember i said it's kind
of looks like he's just getting ready
his offseason started you know oh i'm
gonna lose the weight get really get
really clean my body like you know
humming on all cylinders and then i'm
gonna start to work out and put weight
on and start doing sprints and running
and things like that so he's basically
started his offseason process way late
because he's been dealing with the drama
of some of this stuff early on in the
off-season um but but like the guy we
saw there to me he's the key to the
situation even though he's not to blame
he's the guy that's gonna make it happen
and soothe it over and talk to him and
you know eventually maybe get rogers in
a place where he's just like
hey man come on you know i you know hey
the front office screw them but you know
we want you back come on let's do
something together it's gonna be on him
and how he approaches that relationship
and continues to
make rogers feel comfortable from the
coaching end and the locker room end to
kind of coax them back in there and i
think that's where you know matt lefore
is gonna have to earn some money over
the next month just to make sure that
all goes smooth
and and it's a minefield for him because
if he's having exactly directly with
rogers and says something to rogers that
rogers then if he ever has any
communications with brian good right mr
mark murphy
says well the floor told me this
or if leflore says something to
goodikoonst or murphy and then they say
to rogers well the floor is i mean he
really is in the middle of this he's
caught in the crossfire anything he says
cannon will be potentially used against
him maybe not maliciously but
you're trying to mediate this dispute
and you're dealing with some fairly
stubborn individuals
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports